Efe o sabah dedesinin bahçesinde iki şeyi aynı anda gördü.
Kümesli tabuk, yumurtalarının üstünde kıpırdamadan oturuyordu.
Ahırın köşesinde kedi, yeni doğmuş yavrularını yalıyordu.
Yavru kediler daha o günden annelerine benziyordu.
Yumurtaların içinde ne olduğunu ise kimse göremiyordu.
Efe merak etti.
Biri doğuyor, öteki yumurtadan çıkıyordu.
Cevap, hayvanlarda üreme ve gelişme çeşitliliğinde saklıydı.
Efe işin başına üremeye bakmaya karar verdi.
Hayvanların çoğu eşeğili ürer.
Bir erkek üreme hücresi ve bir dişi üreme hücresi birleşir.
Erkek üreme hücresine sperm denir.
Dişi üreme hücresine ise yumurta denir.
Ama bu ikisinin nerede buluştuğu her şeyi değiştirir.
Efe bahçenin alt ucundaki gölete indi.
Suyun içinde balıklar sığ kıyı boyunca yüzüyordu.
Dişi balık yumurtalarını doğrudan suya bırakır.
Erkek balık da spermlerini aynı suya bırakır.
Sperm ve yumurta dış ortamda suyun içinde birleşir.
Buna dış dörlenme denir.
Açıkta risk çoktur.
Çoğu yumurta yavuya dönüşemez.
Bu yüzden bir seferde milyonlarca yumurta bırakılır.
Kurbağalar da yumurtalarını aynı suya bırakır.
Efe göletten bahçeye geri döndü.
Kümes'teki tavuk hala yumurtalarının üstündeydi.
Kuşlarda dörlenme dişinin mücudunun içinde gerçekleşir.
Yılanda, kertenkelede ve kaplumbağada da böyledir.
Kedi de, atta ve keçide de dörlenme içeride olur.
Buna iç dörlenme denir.
İçeride sperm ve yumurtanın buluşma şansı yüksektir.
Bu yüzden yumurta sayısı çok daha azdır.
Dörlenme tamamdı.
Peki yavru nasıl büyür ve doğar?
Efe aynı bahçede, bunun üç ayrı yolunu gördü.
Birincisi doğurarak çoğalmaktır.
Yavru annenin karnında gelişir ve öyle doğar.
Doğduktan sonra anne sütüyle beslenir.
Kedi, koyun, inek, yarasa, balina ve insan böyledir.
İkincisi yumurtlayarak çoğalmaktır.
Dörlenme içte olur ama yavru yumurtanın içinde gelişir.
Yumurta annenin mücudunun dışındadır.
Tabuk yumurtalarının üstüne yatar ve onları ısıtır.
Buna kuluçka denir.
Yılan ve kaplumbağa yumurtalarını toprağa bırakıp gider.
Üçüncüsü balıklardır.
Onlarda hem dörlenme hem gelişme suyun içinde olur.
Yavru bakımı kuşlarda da ememelilerde vardır.
Yumurtasını bırakıp giden canlılarda yavru bakımı yoktur.
Efe dönerken maydanozun üstünde bir tırtıl gördü.
Bazı canlıların yavruları erginlere hiç benzemez.
Tırtıl bir süre sonra kendini kozanın içine kapatır.
Kozadan çıkan artık tırtıl değil kelebektir.
Bu büyük değişime başkalaşım denir.
Kurbağa yavrusunun önce solungaçları ve kuyruğu vardır.
Efe kümese döndüğünde yumurtalardan biri çatlamıştı.
Her canlının neslini sürdürmek için kendine özgü bir yolu vardı.